we're here at the Forbes under 30 Summit
Africa
the president of President masisi a lot
of people are saying in this continent
of 1.4 billion people you went to a
country of 2 million people why I know
why
but I'd like to hear from you why
you know you go to a country where
there's the greatest chance of success
the greatest chance of reaching out to
the very 1.4 billion people our
telecommunications infrastructure
particularly TV and uh Nick linkages
with satellite technology can reach the
1.4 billion I think one of the biggest
challenges Remains the one of language
and so we'd work on that and provide a
multilingual
programming for that but we represent a
country that is stable
that's forward-looking that has no known
enemies that is a member in good
standing of the EU and sadek the UN a
country that is the oldest longest
stabilest multi-party democracy on the
continent the Cradle of peace and
stability yes right here and a country
that promotes a private sector and
protects the private sector with our
independence of the Judiciary and our
ability to settle differences quite
timelessly and uh and and and and
comfortably yeah to everybody a
respected governance system and
architecture and so when you talk about
Botswana
you talk of integrity and it's known and
uh and accepted by all our our our
compatriots in Africa and the world that
drove no rule of law no entrepreneurship
no no no vibrant business system tell us
what you're doing to foment
entrepreneurship in Botswana
well um you know last year we were here
and I made the announcement that we're
going to form a new ministry a Ministry
of Entrepreneurship
so it's one year old so our result right
at the top is to promote
entrepreneurship it's a culture that's
needed particularly when you position
that within the context of a population
Dynamics we're a very young country a
very young continent and it is the
efficacy
an efficaciousness of young people
that drive for young people and their
inspiration and hope that's provided by
a government and governance system
that's going to drive Innovation and
solutions to problems the world
when we
when we first talked about bringing this
here we talked about you know I remember
you uh mentioning that you wanted
Botswana to be the Singapore of Africa
you wanted to be the Israel of Africa uh
you know talk a little bit about that
the idea of a laboratory here in
Botswana you know Botswana is
resourced enough in terms of the
attitudes the willingness of those in
leadership in the government financially
resourced enough and in the governance
system sufficiently positioned to make
the fastest and most impactful change
it is a country that's well disposed to
trying out new ideas because our hope
our whole development trajectory is
premised on learning from others and so
we have a culture of that
I don't know where else it could succeed
better than in Botswana
and how is the how is the diet the
tradition of diamonds here in Botswana
how has that helped or hindered your
your drive for entrepreneurship diamonds
have been a a marvelous you know
Endowment for us and we've done our best
to uh really uh
um reposition ourselves on the back of
the earnings from diamonds first we
educated our people two we built our
infrastructure and we continue to three
is we relate with others in Commerce
terms and we're able to do that and
right now we build the world's biggest
diamond sorting valuation Center we have
12 sites a year people come from all
over the world so the place for diamonds
globally with good governance and
prominence is Botswana and and we want
to use this advantage to catapult
ourselves with respect to
entrepreneurship and development of
businesses a little bit all right so we
have the largest last question we're the
largest audience of entrepreneurs and
young entrepreneurs in the world what
you know you made it very clear Botswana
is open for foreign investment and open
for for you know startups to come based
here what's what's the what's the
elevator pitch as the well the elevator
pitch is right here where we are was on
a digital and Innovation Hub
um it's it's settled within uh what's
called a special economic zone so there
are many many advantages that we provide
for persons to come here so we want to
attract those you know one of the things
that we're also trying to do because
we're constantly iterating with young
people so we see this as an opportunity
to iterate with them more so that we can
make the pitch even better as we link
with our tertiary institutions and so
you know in terms of financial stability
in terms of banking in terms of startup
capital in terms of technologists in
terms of the inspirators or persons who
have done it before and to incubate them
we want to provide the best home for
that and we'll continue to engage with
the rest such as with Forbes you know in
your networks to make this your home
well we're very glad you're our home in
Africa and we look forward to not only
are we having a great event here but we
we've already
confirmed that we're coming back next
year we can't wait so again we
appreciate we appreciate you hosting us
uh and I think people have been very
impressed with what they've seen so but
again thank you for your time it's going
to be bigger
it's going to be better
and more impactful next year